THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 2100 OF
THE SWING SPACE, AND I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO COME
TO THE HEARING ROOM. AND IT
LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE SHALL TAKE A ROLL CALL.
CABALLERO PRESENT. CIAO HERE,
JONES. ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER
HERE. BRADFORD BRADFORD. HERE
SARTO SARTO HERE, WAHAB. WE HAVE
A QUORUM. BEFORE WE BEGIN. I
WANT TO RECOGNIZE AND THANK OUR
FORMAL FORMER CHAIR AND GOOD
FRIEND, SENATOR PORTANTINO FOR
HIS DILIGENT DILIGENCE, HARD
WORK AND COMMITMENT TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND, UH, WE WISH HIM
THE BEST. I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT I ACKNOWLEDGED HIS
LEADERSHIP. I'M ALSO HAVE A
BIRTHDAY CELEBRATION. BUT SINCE
SHE'S NOT HERE, WE'LL WAIT UNTIL
SHE GETS HERE SO WE CAN
EMBARRASS HER. UM BUT WE ARE
READY TO BEGIN OUR HEARING, AND
WE HAVE ONE WELL, AND THE OTHER
THING IS THAT I'VE BEEN ASKED,
UH, IF I INTEND TO CONTINUE THE
TRIVIA. UH, UM, DISCUSSION THAT,
UH, MY PREDECESSOR, AND ALL I
HAVE TO SAY IS MORE ON THAT
LATER. I'M GONNA LEAVE YOU IN
SUSPENSE. SO WE'RE GONNA BEGIN
OUR OUR HEARING. TODAY WE HAVE
ONE URGENCY MEASURE ON TODAY'S
AGENDA, SO THIS SHOULD BE A
SHORT HEARING. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS INDICATED THAT THEY
DO NOT HAVE A FILE ON THE
MEASURE SO THEY WILL NOT BE
PRESENT TO TESTIFY. BEFORE WE
BEGIN. I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESS TO LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY
TO THE FISCAL AS ASPECTS OF THE
BILL AND TO PLEASE REFRAIN FROM
LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS AND
REPEATING REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY OR COMMENTS AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE, UH, THE TESTIMONY
THERE AT THE MIC AT THE PODIUM.
SO UM, WE HAVE A QUORUM AND
WE'RE READY TO GET GOING AND
WE'LL TAKE UP THE ONE ITEM ON
OUR AGENDA. A B 1887 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, UH, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 1887, WHICH WILL EXTEND THE
APPLICATION DEADLINE FOR STATE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS FROM
APRIL 2ND TO MAY 2ND AS YOU
KNOW, THIS BILL IS A RESPONSE TO
THE ONGOING ISSUES WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW
FEDERAL FREE APPLICATION FOR
FEDERAL STUDENT AID COMMONLY
KNOWN AS FSA. THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
HAVE MORE TIME TO SOLVE THE
ONGOING ISSUES WITH FFA
IMPLEMENTATION, INCLUDING THE
BARRIER PREVENTING STUDENTS WITH
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS FROM
COMPLETING THE FAST MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THIS BILL WILL HELP
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
COMPLETE THE FAFA, ALLOWING THEM
TO ACCESS THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO BEGIN
THEIR COLLEGE CAREER. THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS NOTES THAT
THIS BILL MAY RESULT IN A
SAVINGS FOR THE GENERAL FUND ANY
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD IMPOSED ON
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION IN
OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS
SHOULD BE MINOR AND ABSORBABLE
WITHIN THE EXISTING RESOURCES
WITH ME TO TESTIFY OR ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS IS JAKE BREMER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. AS WELL AS MARCOS
MONTES WITH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE ATTAINMENT
NETWORK. VERY VERY GOOD. UH, WE
THIS ISSUE HAS SOME URGENCY, UM,
IN GETTING IT TO THE GOVERNOR,
SO WE'LL BE ENTERTAINING A DUE
PASS MOTION. UH WE'RE READY FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FORWARD,
UH, CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT, HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ABOUT THE ISSUES
WITH THE FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS OR, UM, HOW THIS
MEASURE WOULD IMPACT OUR
EXPECTED EXPENDITURES ON
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS. VERY
GOOD. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU. CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARCOS MONTEZ WITH THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COLLEGE
ATTAINMENT NETWORK. UM YEAH,
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THIS BILL,
AND HOW MAKING SURE HELPING
STUDENTS GET ACCESS TO THE
FINANCIAL AID. UM, THEY DESERVE.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ASHLEY WALKER
WITH NAAMAN ON BEHALF OF NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT, CITRUS COLLEGE AND
MOUNT SAN ANTONIO COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
JESSICA, ALONG WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON.
SYLVIA SOLIS SHAW HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE OVER 29,000, FACULTY,
PROFESSORS, LIBRARIANS AND
COACHES OF THE 23 CAMPUSES OF
THE èC S¼ U SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? THEN, IS THERE
ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU TO COME FORWARD?
SEEING THAT NÓ ONE RISES IN
OPPOSITION. WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. I'LL MOVE
THE BILL. NÓ NÓ NÓ NÓ NÓ NÓ NÓ I
HAD THE MIC ON, YOU KNOW. COME
ON. ALL RIGHT. WELL I SEE. I
SAY, I'M GONNA HAVE TO, UH, GET
IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS LADIES
FIRST, SENATOR WAHAB MOVES THE
BILL. UM IF THERE ARE NÓ FURTHER
QUESTIONS, S¼ NONE. YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. UH, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I
VOTE FOR A B 1887. VERY GOOD DO,
UH, WE DO HAVE EMOTION, SO THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR BY SENATOR WAHAB, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. HØI
CRO A. JONES ASHBY. BECKER.
BECKER I, BRADFORD BRADFORD IS
SARTO IAB. PERHAPS I. CURRENT
VOTE IS 5 TO 0. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL FOR THE REMAINING
MEMBERS. UM IT WILL PASS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. I THINK.
SEE, THAT'S. THE SENATOR PROPES
COMMITTEE IS BACK IN SESSION.
UH, WE ARE ON A B 1887, AND
WE'RE GOING TO FINISH UP THE
ROLL CALL. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. JONES JONES, I,
ASHBY ASHBY. I 7 TO 0. THAT BILL
IS OUT. UH THANK YOU FOR
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S HEARING
. WE HAVE NOW CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA AND THE MEETING OF THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU, EVERYBODY.